hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood we
are i looked at the time it's 10 10.
we are not ready to end the game just
yet because we have a whole left turn
part
of the world left to explore so we're
going to do just that what's my bag
situation look like
totes good except i need to cook this
doink 10 000 10
000 there is no way ah there might be a
way let me
put away the alcohol too i don't know
why i still have that alcohol away
and then the shovel uh just in case
you know just in case i need the space
okay we're going
we're gonna go past the church to the
north and we're gonna take
left until we reach the edge of the
forest on that side
okay oh hey bud oh hey bud
hi bud okay
there we go i can get them if they just
charged
me i can
noise noise
oh hello come here you come on
am i gonna sneak up on you oh i am never
done that before
oh god oh god you are faster than i
thought you'd wow
i dodged that oh my god that too
oh my god i'm dodging this yeah
my god i dodged every one of those
i dodged every one of those every single
one of those
i my god not
joking i did
where what freaking oh it's round two
baby
dodge oh my god not again oh my god i'm
dodging oh my god
why are you freaking scream
oh my god oh my god oh my god
i dodged it every time that's what i did
i dodged it
every time there's another one this is
some
dense mushrooms don't move a
muscle don't move a musty
okay okay i gotta
actually look god oh my god
this is horrible why did i go through
here i have no idea
oh my god for this this is why
apparently
horrible horrible horrible horrible
horribly oh
do i have no landmarks i do what is this
one
old woods some landmark i don't know i
don't even dignify with a
mark ah well this has gone horribly
wrong
not really many landmarks in the old
woods apparently
seems to be mostly a whole lot of
nothing it's got to be some goodies in
here oh
what is this hello why do i have to time
her on a corp
search never had that before
creepy oh oh it's a trap that's why it
was an ambush
oh i see i see i see i see i see i see
oh oops oh my god have i completely
forgotten how to play this game
it's just got less range than i think it
does
you got to be really up close on the x i
almost like the shovel better
i almost like the shovel better i don't
i need a stick for something i forget
what
oh god there's a couple of them oh my
god i
where's my bandages i don't know how
about a gun you ever ever see a gun
there you go you wanna you wanna dance
buddy
you wanna dance buddy yeah you walk away
ah
my god ah i'm gonna eat these logs
crunch a munch crunch yeah it's just the
axe is great and all but
honestly the shovel might have been
better just on a sheer
like range thing where'd you go buddy
you run away
big baby still say i'm there really
insanity insanity i got to start making
my way back soon
oh my god where where where where oh my
god it's uh it's a dog okay
that's okay come on attack
and jump gotcha okay
hey yeah what did i just do on the map
did i mark it oh creepy how creepy house
wait what creepy house what makes it so
creepy
and do i wanna know oh no i'm not gonna
like this house am i
how do i get in
nice oh here we go i think i've got just
enough time to explore the creepy house
which sounds super lovely hello you know
what i'm going to turn on my lamp
turn on my lamp great
oh that sounds good
oh that sounds good oh that sounds good
just reloading preemptively
do i have the key none of my keys fit
all right you know what
actually that's uh i i i'm okay with
that
i'm okay with that of all the places for
me to left to explore in this place i
get the creepy house
yeah i'm all right you know i'm i'm
a-okay
this entire adventure was a bit of a
mistake just a bit of a mistake i need
to set up my fire traps
i need to put gas in the generators i
gotta do tons of work
where am i now oh i'm home apparently oh
i'm home
excellent okay so what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna make a few traps
i've got a bear trap there which is fine
and i've got
this door here how much scrap metal i'm
working with 13
i could make more bear traps or i could
try to do the gas
thing which honestly i might be more
interested in
yeah i don't have time to really wait
around so let's go ahead and try
i'm just gonna put gas down here so
there's a puddle of gas by the door
there
that's a nice puddle i'm gonna make a
puddle of gas
right here nice good
puddle of gas there and then a little
gas right here
and so basically all i have to do is
chuck the match at it
and it'll go i'm not gonna do it now
because that would be dumb
okay ready as i'll ever be i don't know
if those things stay
but hopefully they do other than that
i'm pretty ready i don't have my
molotovs do i
i'll go nah you know what i'm not i'm
gonna stick to these
gas patches that should work
okay here we go here comes an uneventful
night
oh never really been wind before
uh oh no do i have my flares oh god do i
have my flares
yes i have my flares okay okay
i got him uh-huh
oh i don't like that
oh hey can you not oh can you not
can you not oh my god throw it
burn it who's burning is anybody burning
you burning was there nothing there
okay weird okay i guess i'll put more
gas down
you know what i'm gonna oh my god oh my
god oh my god
i don't know what's doing that oh my god
how are you doing that stop that
did you get stuck i think that was him
getting stuck on the thing
yep i'm gonna get you yeah i'm gonna get
you yep
gotcha close the door
check the body perfect close it
okay oh we've got steps over here
okay is that a hit on this door
oh my god burn it burn it burn it burn
it
oh my god throw the goddamn match
there you go yeah burn you little
bastards ow
try me try me try me i never should have
gotten the
the vision when you get hit okay
the banshees never have anything on him
oh my god i need to uh get the bandage
out
just because i want the i want the
reoccurring
oh yeah you got you got got didn't you
you could got by the chain
[ __ ] come in here i i dare you he's
probably stuck on the chain but i don't
know how that works
what is going on out there
oh [ __ ] oh god mistake mistake
oh my god oh my god yeah no i missed oh
my god oh my god not again not again not
again oh my god
oh my god open open close it throw the
match
oh my god
okay i'm assuming that these
toys are for quests that i either didn't
get
or they're not quests at all and they're
just random items
that might be it so i'm gonna do a trade
with the trader the man grabs my arm and
pulls me closer a strong smell of
mushrooms assails my nostrils the old
sack covering his body slides down
revealing his chest
covered in horrid gross it is fused with
a porous helmet
pulsating to the rhythm of his breath
i'm starting to feel dizzy
without loosening his grip the man
raises his left arm and brings his
forearm to my face
it's pale as paper and reads do not open
the door
let's stick together i mean maybe not my
dude okay toy is
not sold and this guy takes pretty much
everything
you know what actually the odd stones i
don't know if i should
there's still the spooky house but i
don't have a key for it there's so many
things that i don't have
that i wish i did but i just don't you
know yes yes you do
okay you know the deal all right i'm
gonna try i'm gonna trade up a bit
so i don't know about the possibility of
coming back
i don't even know if that's gonna be a
thing they said dress for success or
something along those lines so i'm going
to get everything that i think i'm going
to need
for a new safe base but other than that
not 100 sure if i'm going to be able to
get anything any of this
like this might be finality i have no
idea
so i'm gonna bring some of these weird
knick-knacks for some reason
i don't know why maybe not the wedding
ring maybe the toy i would
the quest would tell me but the toy
makes me feel good it makes me feel
happy so that's what i'm gonna keep
on the hunting rifle that makes also
makes me feel happy and makes me feel
safe
okay this is about as good as it's gonna
get so i guess this is gonna be goodbye
to the trader for now
i have no idea but uh that's all the
time i got now so
i'll take this ammo and i'll be on my
way
uh you don't have any rifle bullets do
you i don't even know what the
i have no idea what it takes yeah
whatever too late too late to find out
i'm just gonna go grab the medium
magazine and then i'll be on my way
hoping that's what it is
all right i'm just gonna go uh no
pussyfoot in time
there's no time to pussyfoot i will not
[ __ ] these feet
i will not whoa mama
whoa mama uh you know actually i'm gonna
pass i don't have inventory space to do
pretty much anything
i'm gonna go down to the house that's to
the
bottom here i'm gonna see if i can make
my way through it from the top
i'm guessing that if i'm coming at it
from this side
it's been going to be okay and i
switched back to my shovel because
slow as it is damn did it have some
reach
all right um oh it says says i'm here
there oh there yeah oh hey mushies okay
weird just a string of mushies
okay got it
hey buds
oh used to be an outhouse or something
now it is a
okay okay
that is very strange i can't look at
anything here
well that's because there is nothing
here hello
oh no oh no it is so different
flicker magazine a bible weekly magazine
for the youth
oh this is so different
that is so bizarre that's throwing me
off so hard ah
i need a key here the burned house
there were people in here at one point
there were i'm through
okay hey haven't been in this area in a
while this is still nice
oh look it's the bear trap out in the
open it's not even covered
wow oh boy the worst thing i had to
worry about here was just a couple of
stray dogs and maybe a deer or two
oh yeah oh the old safe house oh my
goodness
oh has it really been so long
hey that well's looking mighty tasty
slurp
oh it's still all barricaded up look at
this man i really took this for granted
still don't know the code to that
let's uh i guess light this one
i don't know should we i've got a
mushroom i
i don't think it'll make a difference at
this point
i'm it's not like i'm gonna well i guess
i have to now
the oven's lit again
it's whatever okay all right i'm gonna
go if i remember where the place is
which i think i do
it's over to the left here man i re
coming back here
is bizarre especially knowing what i
know now about the game
especially knowing how the game works
but the fact that the game is equally as
threatening and foreboding even now
like it's it's a trip it's a doozy was
it here yet it was in here i think
definitely in here hello remember me
i should take everything i need with me
coming back may prove impossible
yeah uh well i'm doing my best man i i
don't know what i need but i got a lot
of goodies so
let's go for it dude i don't know
you have not prepared me for anything i
have no idea
of the things i'm about to face i have
no idea what threats are lurking down
here
i have no idea what is lying ahead
how did i not look at that how did i not
look at that
i just have no idea about anything
haven't been in here in so long i do
love returns like this like
coming back like with a sense of
accomplishment but i don't know what
i've accomplished
i'm definitely more experienced but am i
better for it i have no idea
hey oh it's you almost forgot you're
gonna be here
are we going uh apparently yes
locked it's my only way out i won't be
able to open it without the key
this is what i'm here for right this is
what it's all about
this is what it's always been about this
is this is the goal
unless it's not
oh oh
i don't know why i expected more fanfare
uh okay backup torch is nice
i don't know who's coming here without
even a light source but some people
might be desperate i guess
huge root white goose slowly seeps from
the giant route
it flows down the hallway as if guided
by some unseen force
i think there's someone still moving
there under the rubble
oh hi
hello oh
where are you i can't can't really see
where you are
oh there you are oh there he is i
stumble upon something amongst the
rubble
a strange soft item the tunnel has
recently collapsed the reinforced steel
protruding from the debris has not been
covered with rust yet
when i gaze into the tunnel i notice a
silhouette of a man on the ground
suddenly the man snaps to life as if
woken from a deep slumber
who goes there i hear a faint
unnaturally distorted male voice
are you are you one of them the man
attempts to get up but fails i can see
him desperately flailing his limbs
around
it's as if his back has been glued to
the ground no please
as i approach him he shuffles his legs
nervously as if trying to retreat into
the collapsed tunnel
i didn't do anything i beg you i just
wanted to pass to get back to my family
the tree is blocked the only way out
the only path home a huge talking tree i
begged it to let me pass
but it wouldn't listen i couldn't
understand what he was saying to me so
we came here
the man props himself up on his elbows
with a huge effort he tries to
straighten his body but something is
firmly holding him by the back and neck
i can't i can't get up the man drops
onto the rubble and go silent he
clenches his fist
my head hurts the man places his hand on
his forehead and feels a strange dent
above his brow he freezes
what's this he carefully inserts his
index finger into the
hole his eyelid twitches my stone
i hear a sound as if an eggshell
cracking the forehead bends under his
hand
oh the stranger pushes another finger
into the hole a thick goo
spews from the wound i can hear his
skull cracking my little stone
the man slowly removes his fingers from
the hole in his head
a colorless ooze dripping from them he's
holding on to something a round object
that's why he swings his left hand and
throws the object at me
a small irregular ball bounces off my
arm and lands at my feet
oh looks like a bullet but it's soft
okay this this is what put me to sleep
his head lifelessly drops to the
concrete floor of the destroyed
tunnel and goes still
what suddenly i can hear a bang of a
metal door followed by the sound of
fading footsteps
it's the doctor what what do you mean
it's the doctor
what about it's the doctor
a big sign of the door reads closed area
well i got nowhere else to go
okay i really don't rusty iron cowbell
oh no oh
what is going on what is the deal
oh what
oh
i just wanted to
return to my family oh
i don't like it i don't like none of it
i like exactly zero of it i just wanted
to sleep
okay oh boy pills and another lantern
you know what you can take your torch
i'll take the lantern the blizzard's
good
i like the lantern this is
horrible
okay there's something ahead at least
oh my god
i will mess you up buddy i will mess you
up i will mess you up
i will mess you up
i will mess you up
oh okay
all right looks like my
what am i looking at strange organic
gross
and um an eyeball oh many eyeballs
oh no no no
no no
okay oh no
no shiny stone shiny sun tied to a
wooden cross
okay a dried body of some man only skin
and bones covered in roots they are
surprisingly well preserved a small hole
in the forehead
i'd say it's been lying there for more
than two years oh no
oh stairs oh that's weird oh that's
weird oh that's weird
huh um
oh
chapter 2
chapter two a damaged compressor used to
refill oxygen
chapter two oh
oh okay oh
my god covered in a strange organic
black shell i won't be able to open it
until i get rid of this
yeah i don't know
okay well it's gone i guess
was it the light that did it i don't
know
okay gas bottle bottle filled with toxic
and high leaf
rusty oxygen tanks are useless chapter
two
hi hello
hi what is that
okay okay
i didn't bring any wood i didn't think
that i would be needing
wood exploding barrel it's filled with a
highly flammable substance it explodes
in contact with fire
this isn't exactly what i was prepared
for
it's covered in a thick layer of dust
like nones been using smells of warm
plastic and burned wires
oh right do i have a work bench or
something
oh no
locked i need a key my own safe house
has a locked room
okay here's a work bench good
is this even gonna work nothing happens
ah yeah that makes sense that does make
sense
i'm in trouble i'm in trouble for a
number of reasons
first and foremost i thought i i
prepared for a fight
i didn't necessarily prepare for a near
permanent excursion
i'm in trouble
weird okay that glows when that shuts
down let's just
fill the generator at least i think
that's still the first step of what i
have to do
how am i gonna survive here i have no
wood i have to go find wood
wood has to be first priority and i
can't eat it as tempting as it is
i gotta keep it out of my mouth
okay very little supplies which is
reassuring
um ah
good oh
good lovely swamp
oh no how am i gonna find any wood here
oh god okay um
i don't know where i am i don't know
where anything is
found village what do you mean found
village what a village
hello
oh it's a banshee no that's not a
banshee
i don't know what that is but it's gonna
die oh
[Music]
dead human spider great
good just hoping that's what that was
yeah i think pistol might be the way to
go
uh yeah yeah this is horrifying this is
awful
this is this is nuts i'm probably not
even close
i thought i was like i thought this was
like oh yeah we're at the end
no no way crows something must scare
them off from the huge
tree crown towering over the village
okay
sure we'll go with yeah on that one
we're gonna go with yeah
there's like nothing they're giving me
like nothing there's like
no scavengeables
there's a number on the ground oh
there's a bunch of weird the word
thieves have been scratched out on the
floor
all right maybe they need to learn how
to spell
there's a wood pile okay i need all the
wood i can get
oh oh
oh nelly hornelli nelly
ah yeah yeah yeah i dropped that
i dropped i keep my pants a little
oh my god
fires which means that someone was here
recently
rubble i have a shovel why would i dig
through the rubble here
why would i do this why am i doing this
great thanks for ruining my shovel
and letting me go through here i'm
guessing that's going to be good but
it's not apparent yet because i haven't
searched in here and reached the dead
end
who are you i don't know man i i don't
even know hi
wait what do you have you're alive the
old man extends his hand blindly trying
to reach me
you're not from around here eh you
cannot be hm
all them lads are dead it's only me me
and he finally finds my arm and grabs it
for a moment he clutches my hand in
silence then i hear him mumbling on his
breath
i don't have anything mate only this
this chair
bloody hell his gaze stopped somewhere
under the leaky barn ceiling
what the old man suddenly jumps up what
are you saying i feel his long
fingernails digging into my hand
ain't no [ __ ] tree that looks like a
tree but those faces
i know i'm buggers every single one of
them so close and
so fake they're not real they're not
from time to time i thank god i went
blind
i don't have to look at them the old man
let's go on my hand to lean against the
broken back of the chair
he sighs with relief it disgusts me it
[ __ ] disgusts me this buggery
this [ __ ] scum all the time i have to
listen to its pathetic blabber
complaining all the time as if we ever
supposed to believe it's human
that it's me zoka yeah right he suddenly
reaches out towards me with both hands
almost falling from the chair he grabs
onto my sleeve
i feel all his weight on me you lad
you've got your hands and legs strong
arms i bet you get rid of that filth
from my village i can't bear another day
of that abomination wailing and sobbing
i want to die in peace [ __ ] hell i
want to die in peace
listen to me i thought about it for a
long time i've had a lot of time to
think for [ __ ] sake his eyes widen his
pupils are milky white
i can feel him climbing in my coat you
need to find the basement
joseek's basement i remember it it's
right next to the tree
the tree is too large so if you can't
reach it from the top you gotta try from
the bottom
find the basement there surely you'll
find the tree's roots
the bloody thing must have roots that's
where they are
destroy them pull them drag them twist
the [ __ ] out of them you'll find a way
hey
i know you will the old man slides down
from my coat straight into his destroyed
wheelchair
for a moment he searches for his stone
which he uses to prop himself up against
the muddy floor of the barn
thank you thank you okay the old man
grabs a photograph feels it then takes
out a small glass object from his pocket
and puts it to his eye
the road the road home what a load of
bollocks
the road to madness is what it is if you
come across some wheels maybe two wheels
so that i could fix my chair maybe you
would benefit from it as well
what are you going on about the
wheelchair war took my legs wankers
burned my house and pigs it was years
after the war they said it was to fight
the disease so they said
i'm mizoka the disease took her from me
all i have is this wheelchair
and this land no one lives around here
anymore
and everyone is dead only sometimes
sometimes i hear footsteps they wake me
up at night the sound
of bare feet against the floor and bells
sort of
they come out of nowhere they move
towards the trees then come back
they pass me and fall silent they're
like a nightmare
a bloody nightmare years ago when my
eyes were good
people used to pass through here they
would leave their huts and go
there where that damn tree grows they
would often leave at night
so that no one could see them they went
into the deep dark woods and never came
back
some of them would say they're going
home but most of them were silent
i don't know the land has changed the
trees have cut us off from the rest of
the world
but home for me has always been right
here
then that monstrous moaning abomination
grew out of the ground
it blocked the passage and that's that
no one has managed to pass through since
then
maybe people found some other place
maybe they died at the swamps just like
us
it used to be different here first the
woods changed
the trees started sprouting up
everywhere we were cut off
and the water flooded our fields people
went crazy out of hunger
they fought over foods so what have you
been eating
it's a good question i guess but won't
worry about too much
a blockade sure
i'm sure that's fine he didn't need that
shirley and the tree
right and the tree so you're telling me
that no one lives here
absolutely zip zilch all right uh i
i can't go this way just yet i really
desperate fish i'll leave you the fish
and the tree
yeah yeah the tree i get it
the tree i'm not gonna repair the
doorway here
are they out of their gourds they must
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
they must be out of their gourds they
would have to be out of their
ow they must be 100
out of gourd okay i'm not going that way
yet because apparently i got a whole lot
more game left
and i had no idea and i'm down for it
but holy crap
oh my god oh the trees
these trees are legit legit dangerous
now the trees are no joke now
oh how am i gonna survive tonight i have
no idea
i i legitimately have no idea how i'm
going to survive i have nowhere near
enough wood
oh hey bud hey bud hey buddy
oh oh god oh god you're off your chain
sorry bud
okay sorry i had to do it i had to do it
and do it
i had to do it gas
fabric i don't need more fabric that's
what i definitely don't need
the odd meat who needs it
hole oh weird that actually was the
thing
bear trap too oh god
is that someone bashing their head
against one
that's what that sounds like
i don't know oh that's a big
fire oh hey bud there you are i'll put
you out of your misery
oh okay fun
oh nice dodge i can do that too oh god
not not now not now not now god damn it
uh oh i gotta get back i gotta get back
oh what is that oh what is oh what is
this
oh god it's the pain i i remember
feeling that i remember distinctly
feeling that
okay something's after me okay great
medium bullet huh try to remember that
this is gonna be a doozy
how do i need i need a whole thing
i basically need the whole thing is what
it just said i needed
where's my wood chopper do i have a wood
chopper
oh wood chopper there we go okay log log
okay what can i possibly do what could i
possibly do
i there's like basically
nothing i can do oh i've got this huge
opening
which you know frankly i wonder if i
could just pour gas on this thing and
light it ablaze like could i do that i
would love to know
because i don't think having this in my
home
is a good idea i'm gonna try i'm gonna
try to burn this thing to the ground
because why not right let me just excuse
me
dribble this on here and take a match
and just
chuck that bad boy over there
all right that did nothing okay good
great that did nothing
fantastic as good as this is gonna do
i'm boarding this up
and as good as this is gonna do i'm
boarding this up
and then i run out of wood uh it's gonna
have to be this room right
oh god i don't have enough anything
yeah i'm just gonna need bear traps okay
um i don't have enough to apparently
repair this doorway i need nine nails i
didn't bring my nails
oddly enough uh so yeah i'm just gonna
be caught out in the open with my pants
down
oh god why did i do that before i was
done going out i could have made more
because i'm incredibly stupid more
matches
a rag that's all i have
this night's gonna suck
oh wow there's a oh god
i hate that does it contain oh oh
12 september 1984 we found new signs 17
kilometers
west of the hideout 33.12 circles one
catalog
pattern six unidentified pattern simple
size scribblings of a madman
okay or something important i don't have
a shotgun stop time to give me a shotgun
i don't have it i don't have it i have
nothing
where's the generator god i didn't even
turn the generator on oh my god
oh can i sneak i can't sneak by that oh
my god i'm such an idiot
i got scrap metal yahoo
note oh day one 13 15 hours the
compressor's broken locked in the
trapdoor leading to
underground had to use a blowtorch
[ __ ] moisture uh 1200 hours we took
45 photos of the tree from the
observation point of the vicinity of 3c
it grew twice its size in a month
really quick even for the local
standards 15 20 hours i'm slowly running
out of oxygen i've sent two men to
search the nearby junkyard maybe we
won't have to go back for
prayer parts for the compressor watch
out for the cottage near the junkyard
mark building on the map
someone could be living there 18 12
hours at least 10 locals lurking between
the trees
how do they know about us we won't be
able to gather our equipment in time
the risk of getting detected is too high
need to evac
where what where are we and
what where's the generator where's the
generator
oh there it is oh my god oh my god oh my
god
oh my god oh my god i'm going to make
more quickly quickly i'm going to make
more
bear traps uh i'm going to put that away
that way that way that way
uh this that away uh bear traps spare
traps bear trips
okay we're going we're going we're going
we're going we're going we're going
we're going we're going ah repair repair
repair repair the shovel repair the
shovel
repair shovel love it love it you love
to see it you'll love to see it you'll
love to see it almost making this too
easy on me
i'm gonna put this right on the big
stupid eye right on your big dumb
eye you stupid it's the first time i've
ever done this with just a completely
open doorway which is awesome
okay oh hate that
oh no no no no where's my uh flares
flares flares
flares flares six
oh of course
come back to us
you know i'm trying man i'm trying i'm
really trying dot dot dot yeah okay
yeah i don't have anything to say soon
soon
soon i'm close okay
oh that's not good oh that
oh there we go that's the thing
okay okay
oh yeah something's coming
oh no did poochie get sklunked
okay i am appreciative
that the night is not too terrible on
this first night in this
never mind holy [ __ ] what was that
oh god i just had to say something i had
to say something oh my god i have to say
something
oh my god i had to open my big dumb
mouth
my big stupid dumb mouth
oh i just had to say something oh no
oh my god no
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the three what do you mean the three the
three what
the three who the three who cares all
right
i had to open my big mouth and open my
huge mouth i can't even get this bear
trap anymore because it's in the doorway
okay you know um that'll be it for this
episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been eventful
illuminating even and apparently there's
a lot more game than i thought
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down the comments below
and as always i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you